I can hear him I can hear him too mr. X
come and get you
he's been pounding around while we've
been doing like sound checks and setting
up he's been like opening doors and
stomping around you can hear him and I'm
sure you feel great about it yeah
there's been like a lot of stress
leading up to us starting this record
and I haven't gotten into the game yet
but because I have to like hear
everything to make sure it's gonna
record okay he's like stomping around up
there and opening up doors and sniffing
you out I hear him and I'm trying to
like enjoy this intro with you and this
sweet fan art that I got your stress
it's fine I read through it the stress
level is too damn high I did want to
show you some sweet art we got from sage
this one's really this one's really good
cuz a lot of them are about how you're
like annoying to me yeah this one you
got a cartoon Mary got revenge on me
this one was from resi 5 I think when we
were playing co-op and if I got
somewhere first I would hit a button
that would basically be like come on
come on come on Sheva and you get
floridays when I was in control of the
volume you would mute me all the time
that's where this second this very
important second image of the comic came
from yeah I was wondering what the third
panel would be just you yeah he gave you
some real nice cleavage plus I have some
sort of choker that I don't remember
Sheva wearing but she definitely didn't
have one I think she did and apparently
like eight belts yeah kind of my
aesthetic in real life too it's like it
really captured your annoy say this is
also what you look
like when I eat on stream yeah people
are asking on Twitter about my
misophonia it's gotten better probably
because I don't have to hear you eat as
much yeah I'm not I've heard I think I
was in that conversation as well and it
was cool to hear that because I know you
and Peter both have like some similar
triggers and some like reactions to it
and me Peter also said that he's like
doing a lot better and that's awesome so
yeah so a if you're new this series this
work this is part six of residence you
remake we've played all the other
resonable games you can go back and
watch them if you're new to GameSpot or
our YouTube channel or whatever and be
for those new to the series misophonia
my thing is when I get really really
enraged irrationally at like cloying
noises like chewing or things that other
people consider relaxing apparently with
ASMR like lips smacking and chewing
anything like bowel noises mouth full
noises snoring is the worst but that's
usually not a problem in the workplace
yeah you could never date a snorer
though no sorry not all you know mr. X
is as you can hear straight up we need
to talk about what I'm supposed to be
doing let's like let's talk a little bit
about the things that I did last last
episode I met I unlocked mr. X he's been
following me around I opened up the
final extra storage thing so far which
is amazing and it's been extremely
helpful so I'm really grateful for that
I think I don't think that's the last
one oh good but yes so people pointed
out a critical flaw in my guidance last
because we all know how Wallis I've been
with my guidance so far and I saw a
comment that said that either you've
never played this game before or you
know that's to get an upgrade so that's
why the stars office was red but that's
not a problem
it's it'll anyway back to a drive but
the worry it's not necessary but it
the worst part is is like I was kind of
in a dire straight last episode because
there were there was at least one what
are those things called skinny gross
wall climbers the curse um one mr. X in
that hole they come in to get me and so
I panicked
as I do and ran away and got severely
injured now I've healed but the liquor
and the Xer is still out there so that's
something I have to deal with I have to
get well from the sound it sounds like
mr. X is upstairs now but the liquor
will definitely be there still yes but
you also need to go upstairs you don't
have to but that would help okay well
let's talk about that like what things
am I supposed to be doing like what
should i do first should I do that
should I do the USB first and just come
go get it
it's sort of upstairs where you go up a
floor so it's on the west side but it's
yeah so it's right there you can see it
go to the the private collection room
what's so again it's not necessary and I
didn't even use it for my first two
playthroughs of this game but it'll I'm
pretty sure it's the glass case at the
bottom of the sewer stair case I think I
don't know private collection room what
does that exclamation oh right so you
got one piece of that so it's in your
box right now I think de also I don't
know but I think I still have I have the
heart key I thought I actually had
another key do I not know you used the
diamond one the last time and one so I
have this large deal
alright that's been a clock top and I
have a boxed electronic part so just for
the sake of doing it now I equip the
boxed or and never mind don't worry
about it yet so the piece the electronic
part you need is inside obviously we
that's we can get that later okay so
that's I think your overarching
objective is
to get to the clock tower which is where
the gear will come into play I remember
correctly and that will lead to another
electronic part but yeah you also have
the heart key which I'm racking my brain
to remember where the last door is I
can't remember if it's downstairs or on
because typically you might just not
have seen it yet though like oh go back
to the east side so once you get the
crank handle you can go into the break
room and whatnot
what's where's that piece of what that's
the yeah that's just a map from chief
irons office oh the parking garage
that's the bottom of the elevator that
leads up to chief irons office okay is
that door Oh heart door lock the door is
here and there's a crank handle slot
yeah so the crank handle will also open
up a door on the second floor but I
would say let's go to just get the badge
for now and that dongle yeah there's a
dial lock over here say oh the dialog we
got that combination last we can do that
as well but I think that's where mr. X
is sounds like he is great so uh yeah
the Stars office for now because the
gear is for the clock tower but where am
i down one more floor in the world oh so
I would go up the stairs to where he is
and that would put me here where would
that put me oh here yeah and then you'll
the third floor lockers I hate the
shower room well you figure figure out
where is you can still keep going
upstairs to the locker up there the
third floor Locker okay I might actually
eat tronic part I'd away so I have a
submachine gun I have a regular gun I
have a lot of guns I have about the acid
round
I wouldn't want it the one acid round I
would like the grenade launcher because
I think I have to kill that liquor yeah
I just put those away and you're fine
you got seven slots so do you want me to
keep the machine gun or get rid of it
um good question you don't need that
right now okay so yeah these for defense
about 50 bullets a couple acid rounds
and the boards and a heart key and
that's it yeah alright so I have to kill
this liquor you might not need to if you
if he's not over here and you walk slow
enough for the stairs doc I hear ya he
sounds close sorry I know I'm gonna try
to be less annoying this episode it was
really scary last episode I just want
you to know I thought it's funny well
the liquor come upstairs I don't I don't
know
great that would definitely suck if he
does cuz mr. Eck there I know they can't
go through doors or anything but the
stairs a good question what
oh it's rain sorry yeah I guess you're
I'm [ __ ] so I you have to understand
this is really hard for me like he's
obviously here yeah where is he
like okay so is he not here and I'm just
no he is um go to the bottom of stairs
he's definitely not down the hallway you
could go the long way around if you
wanted to I just don't understand how
much danger I'm in you could go through
the library if that's not trap stairs
maybe you went into there like there she
is Oh
his footsteps are farther away now yeah
that's good
yes um so since you're here I would go
up one more floor to the locker and I
have the combination written down for
last episode I don't know if he's
upstairs or on the second floor
full disclosure but I have the note with
the code cool I'm just like doing these
like breathe exercises that it's like a
Lamaze class
I hear him you might it doesn't sound
like he's on I don't know just where am
I going
oh right there to your left the lockers
right there all right DCM DCM yeah I'm
all right
it's not you I I heard you you're very
clear actually I just can't concentrate
when there's a [ __ ] opening doors
I think he's below you I feel ya Jaime
EDX there you go
what's in here ooh not bad okay cool
now where will I go I try not to
dilly-dally with murderers probably at
this point I think he's I think he's on
the second floor from what I just
sounded like below yeah the best for me
to go around maybe into the storage room
it's not a great situation for me no you
can't I don't think you can because that
white door from the library you can't
get up there yet that's where the hole
in the floor was oh so I'm actually
trapped up here no no sorry you can go
into the library through the West
storage room and then you can go down a
floor you just can't go through that
white door that's where we're
essentially trying to get but you could
I think you could try going down a floor
okay so when I go down the floor am I
trying to go to the stairs stars office
yeah so if you figure out he's on that
floor feel me you all you need to do is
go back to the stairs down into the safe
room right and then you can kind of
reorient right now I don't see much
reason to not try to get the badge
I feel like we're on the same page
can he hear me when I'm going this like
speed you're better off being squired
walking I believe yeah you're doing fine
I'm not running yeah so he might be on
this floor but like you're so far oh
okay so I'm just gonna go to the end of
this hall I'm gonna take a left and then
I'm gonna go into the stars office no
problem
no no it's a good right right there's no
what you can't go that way you know what
I don't [ __ ] have any heels
oh yeah yeah even yeah great I have
faith in you it's right there
doors right there should I run or should
I just no don't run
you're almost there who knows where he
is now he's probably in here no I don't
highly doubt that get get cut YouTube
commenters precious weapon upgrade okay
back back so now or else so go over to
the east side you say okay and go up a
floor it's a blue herb there can you go
to that red door from the east storage
room I think that's just straight-up
lock from this side this one no if the
red door the left yeah that's just
straight-up locking that side so you
need the the crank thing in the library
tape get up there so go down a floor I
think
so you essentially want to get I think
you do need to go back down to the
parking garage so just make your way
toward I could be wrong at this part
I'm hazy on make your way back to the
main hall mm-hmm sort of yeah you want
to go back to the chief's office which
is yeah other side of the okay so I
should go south right take a left out of
the stairs office into the lounge into
the library and into the main hall yeah
okay but keep in mind if he is that way
you just go the opposite direction run
like a [ __ ] the other way
he will not appear because I'm having a
really good game I'm freaking out
nothing's happened I don't like it I
can't even hear him which actually Shh
Lee he's scarier because know you're
letting see you he's in your head don't
let that [ __ ] get you straight left
into straight right into the hall
yes remember in seven when that guy
broke through the door the wall oh yeah
that's how I feel about this Jacob my
thing we know Jack Baker Jack that's how
I feel about this I feel like he's like
gonna kool-aid man into the wall anytime
Dave I feel like I did good
sure oh yeah yeah I'll put away the
donkey and I will acquire one super
health let's see I got a mixer I got I
got two greens and I got a mixed shows
you the mixed and red just do the green
and red could the combined yeah yeah
sorry well cuz you had a separate
greener yeah you don't need the
submachine gun ahem oh right now either
oh yeah that's why you're here
you know I should probably have a
different gun out oh right he could come
in here remember the main hall what yeah
he did the last time
it's he can't go in the other safe rooms
big no the main hall but I was safe he
can come in here yeah II know cuz if you
go upstairs first then that doors gonna
be locked off yeah you got to go this
way into where man yeah this part is
there's not a lot for me to do here
no it's the helicopter oh so you're
going okay you're going to the fire
escape and then up those stairs okay and
because there's this waiting no see that
wavy red line right next to the ladder
on the left of it yes that's a metal
door that you can't open without the
crank don't have it but there's this
fire escape right in the corner yeah
that's what I'm saying so I'll go down a
floor you're gonna make your way to the
fire escape and then go up those stairs
and then you're gonna be there and
you'll just follow that hallway - what
do you want to say follow the I can't I
like be upstairs in the main hall go
through the waiting room and be in the
same hallway oh I see what you're saying
yeah I guess you could I just think you
saw the hallway being blocked off but
I'm going into here into the roof that's
where you want me to be yeah into the
yeah I'm trying to get to roof II okay
to the roof we go so I'm gonna take this
main hall into the fire escape and to
roof great I wonder if there's liquors
in here I forget you know I'll be fine
yeah sure
blind optimism has served us well in the
past oh yeah go up you just said you can
go up through that I know but I thought
you disagreed with me
no no no I I misunderstood what you're
saying like and then I was like I said
oh yeah you can go through there if you
want get to the same spot where is he
where is he the music happened boys
I could you could walk I don't know if
he knows you're here up here yeah
nevermind [ __ ] him
yeah you got some room to move around so
I just go all right
through that door and then take a right
yeah and now left before the door really
fire escape is through the door Oh roof
right I'm dumb sorry I forgot
cuz this is where the helicopter was
before he appeared great now though I
must good what room at her can you know
what there's a saw down those stairs I'm
trying to amber if you went down there
yet
oh you know what there's a there was
like a blue herb around here oh well I'm
not gonna worry about it right now so
down the roof
no I'm that's not the way you need to go
I'm you need to go up a ladder back to
your left but I'm trying to member if
you went down those stairs yeah try
going down the stairs just to check why
because I don't think I'm sure I don't
think we've been down there there's oh
well we've been down there because
that's where I've met mr. X was down
there Oh remember that's where he is
where he be down go down the floor on
the right it's super weird maybe only
Leon can get him why the hell also also
he's following me okay yeah I just got
the wire I hear him
yeah here it is
he's just like pitter-pattering around
somewhere but I don't know where so now
you're gonna go in and then down the
stairs where is he he might be in the
main hall on the others yeah so you're
gonna go to the office through there
right
no it's still healing you're on the
upper floor I just keep walking down a
little bit you're you're gonna chief's
office which is save room it's also the
elevator down to the parking garage
level
god bless the save room I honestly think
you're good on supplies I just go down
okay
should I save again just to be safe sure
I love saving mm-hmm it's so nice it's
so like reassuring and there's no pucks
in this game so I like don't have to
think about it I just save anything can
he come over here or am i I'm safer over
here I think you're safe he wouldn't
even
like an elevator guy he wouldn't dare
you see it's the you turn the gameplay
down is it too loud and I headphones
it's like go up blaring yeah that's
there's also an elevator so there's a
map to your left that you can yeah
there you go um how's that huh that's a
diamond door you already went there um
okay so we have go back to the parking
garage I assume yeah I'm hoping this is
where we go next I am this is I mean
this is pretty much where it the only
place we can go right now cuz I have
that heart key yeah
yeah what's so I go straight I think
that's just straight-up locked this door
and then there's this door but I do
believe there's a liquor in here yeah I
mean I might as well try just to see
because it doesn't do anything yeah okay
now I have to go through that hallway
the good news is is it oh what the [ __ ]
was that go down a floor can you on the
map he wouldn't dare come in here now
down I did go down
oh yeah just one do you mean go
somewhere else no I'm trying to think of
where do you think that this isn't the
right go down that ladder yet or you
came from there what ladder and on the
map it's in the parking garage oh right
I think I came from there um I don't
even know where it is it's like to my
right over here or something yeah it's
right there on the yellow is here left
yeah uh yeah yeah go down want me to go
down there yeah cuz I'm trying to member
what's down here and it's not showing up
on your map I don't remember all right
it's very fog William is there anything
on this floor item box typewriter
machinery room I go down to go down a
floor it's all go up two floors
yeah and that leads right back to the
main hall eventually okay yeah I guess
it's the other way in the parking garage
or I led you astray I don't know that's
okay that's a part of the game without
you I would be like I think I would have
quit cuz I
would have just been like there's
nowhere else for me to go and I do not
wish to die today so something that we
should be aware of is I really do feel
like there's liquor in this area yeah I
mean you could just kill him you have a
decent amount of grenades already I'm
hoping the door at the end of hallways a
heart door maybe I killed it oh yeah no
that's when you fought like three of
them in that other room when they heat
whatever this does not look good
damn oh is that tied to the okay so it's
not in here
but now we know what wait what's to the
left
that's a couch it's like one of those
what do you call them the beds that you
like fold into the ceiling to save room
yeah like a it's like a person's name
like a Barney bed or something someone
help me a Murphy bed Murphy bed got a
party bet that you don't normally hear I
hear Murphy pretty often Barney okay so
I'm going back upstairs it looks like
yeah if he ever an open your map sorry
oh I don't know where the [ __ ] I am you
know I would have I would have led us
astray eight times I fairly certain I
know where to go and I know why I didn't
know where to go so go left the last
heart door is the door on the north end
of the records room and the reason is
this is very dumb and it's not a good
excuse but see the club key door yeah
you don't get the club key is Claire you
get it as Leon and I forgot there's the
door on the north end so I saw the club
key and I thought oh that's just the
room for Leon but that's where the
second of electrical panel is and so go
back to the main hall through the West
office and then yeah to that white door
is the last heart door great um well the
first thing I have to honest to God oh
[ __ ] how do I get that [ __ ] out of here
I'm so dumb it's to the left that that
door that's like down the stairs a
little bit to your left
it's like a whole thing to get here
ah it's okay Oh what have been you have
to you were I know but you were okay so
you were already in the main hall you
could have just gone through the West
office and right there that's true but I
you have to make your way back across
the like the whole station with mr. X
roaming around that is true all these
things you've not yet we're like we've
opened that the overall loop of the
station so we can circle with him we
still have like road blocks you've
harmed me royally but I thinks if we can
solve this it wouldn't be Knievel if I
wasn't [ __ ] you over yes I just kind
of three no you're fine so you're gonna
go up and then out oh yeah and then out
yeah - the balcony again I don't hear
him yes I do when I go up the stairs I
take a left to the balcony is that right
I sort of straight where's the balcony
to the left that's let's straight it
straight now I yeah yeah but left at the
other door yet god I swear I hear him I
would actually like recommend going down
anyway cuz if he is around this is an
easy way to area somebody's down here
that's that you're still fine it's an
open area more open than the hallways
are where am I going to the fire escape
yeah and then just literally following
that hallway all the way around to the
main hall through the waiting room okay
[Music]
it's probably fine I'm just upset what
nothing
I just sense him I just feel his
presence
oh he's downstairs I think yes okay yeah
he doesn't know where you are great uh
you're going through okay look stops
standstill you're going through that lit
up door down there right there you mean
he went through no no no that went to
the right yeah that's the west office
you're gonna go through there back to
the out sort of outside of the weapons
where you got the submachine gun not the
submachine gun I'm sorry the grenade
launcher hopefully he's preoccupied in
that liquor hallway how come he doesn't
kill this guy cuz miss mr. exes what
what I try to think if you can just kill
him now you're gonna be going back there
on the guy will hear me and will kill me
yeah I just I'm imagining a scenario in
the future where you're dealing with
Marvin and him in the main hall now
you're right I would just if you're
undetected right now I would just keep
going okay so where am I going
just through this office into that like
u-shaped hall in and to the left door
just to that white door yeah to the
records room
and that should be the last heart door
so you can dispose that afterward and
you should get that's a hanging body I'd
me that's [ __ ] him did you not see it
it was okay no that is him this is not a
discussion well either way I keep going
now
that was him it was him he's here he saw
me I can't believe you didn't see this
can you come in here can you come in
here
okay wait hon take up take it nope keep
it boss if he can so there's a grenade
right there regardless it you've got
like a bookshelf you can cat and mouse
around to your left where is the grenade
just like right on the other side of
this table but there's also a liquor in
this hallway do you not hear that music
I [ __ ] told you just can't yeah I
just you're fine oh I wouldn't have
gotten the grenade you're fine just just
keep going through the door yeah just
keep doing this completely fine oh I'm
going through just so am i right that's
what's happening I this is not a
discussion okay but wait hold on
so now you got the crank for the library
that's very good what's the quick yeah
just go through the west office back to
the main hall that he's gonna hit me
he's I think you he's right he running I
know I I believe you I'm just saying
pick up you could save in the main hall
if that would make you feel better
there's a zombie in there you can still
save but yeah you might now that mr. X
knows where you are this might be a good
opportunity to kill Marvin anyway with
your handgun okay and then you're going
up to the new library Oh what what no
nothing it's it's going according to
plan I can't I don't have time all right
ooh man all right this is gonna get
dicey okay see me yeah just go
but shy up we should talk about it so
okay the reason I said [ __ ] is because
you're about to do this puzzle that you
have to like you need time to do those
yeah because it's moving those
bookshelves in the library so you can
walk across that gap and then that will
get you up to the third floor of the
main hall which is the clock tower with
the electrical part which we can worry
about later it's all balls there was um
powder in the record room I missed it so
where's the library yeah back up this
second so you're just saying I have to
lose him first that's all yeah though
you can still keep heading toward the
library just the long route so go I'm
downstairs so what you sh what I want
you to do is go through reception all
the way around that long hallway okay
make your way to the dark room stairs go
up those and then you can go to the
library from there I think by that time
you'll have lost him I have to do
another loop Marvin oh my god I got it
for now let's just get to the dark room
save room you'll be fine but I forgot
about this thing just I can shoot it
yeah oh just Miss critten ate him down
on the d-pad and then he's on the
ceiling right now though nice keep going
where is it just keep literally just
follow this hallway the entire length of
the west side to the what though to the
operations room and then you're gonna
where essentially kind of going back to
where we were but we wouldn't the long
road but mr. X was right behind us so oh
you have boards you could board up that
oh this hallway [ __ ] I need Shh is this
the bad hallway yeah but you took me to
the bad hallway I forgot about it
oh okay just reload that on the run and
get ready to see some zombies I don't
want to just run are you red yeah you
got a heal okay I don't know I hope a
different one if I could just turn
around and shoot it uh yeah but yeah you
should do that because you don't want
him and their zombies I had to contend
with
[ __ ] oh my god there's so much going on
you should you can also just grenade the
stood in front of you - I I like
literally don't know what to do so okay
there's there's wait okay wait hold on
okay it's not as bad as you think so you
have like a ton of defensive items right
now I would just run straight at the
zombie in front of you let him grab you
and do the l1 you mean behind
he's behind you now but he's in the path
where you're trying to go yeah and just
get ready press eyeliner hey
[Music]
on the bright side you also an might
have hurt the other one um is the mr.
Excel
yeah he's in this room isn't he
no no he's on this room there's no way
oh there's no way he went into Westville
office cuz you wanna I don't believe you
I don't believe me either
um it might where me treat you a dark
room okay yeah so you could either go
through the blue door I would go through
oh there's a liquor in there actually no
go up to the crate and go where that
arrow is it's that vent you crawl period
like the beat there's just like a lot
going on once you see that opening
you're much safer just keep going to the
dark room yeah and I are gonna take Oh
what is that it's just a regular dude I
would just pistol him shoot his legs a
lot I just don't feel like I got a lot
going on for me like not leather yeah
not that far from the dark room you use
the defensive items like you should have
you sold two more but that's not a
[ __ ] zombie you got to just grenade
him
oh my god I'm stuck yeah you gotta just
go forward just gives make it to the
dark room he's gonna kill me
no we wait you're on green aren't you no
what do you want caution I think you'll
make it he's going to hit me if you
really want to you could grenade him to
stun him I think what foreign aid hey do
you have one more oh I'd have to turn
around though cuz I need to reload as
you can see he's fairly close even if he
hits you I don't think it'll kill you
just it like right now you just have to
the dark room okay organ eight him
grenade him not great
dr. photographer I I'm not great you
made it you made it did I yeah and you
boarded up this window it all worked out
C there's a Plan C even Claire knows now
you got help you got a lot of stuff Mary
oh my god dude did you see how many
things went wrong for me I think that's
what makes this entertaining I could not
have I don't think but I orchestrated
and entertaining you you have harmed me
irreparably all right
[Music]
I bring some healing Oh should you all
you did it
what other gunpowder's do you have do
you just have high high grade because
you have a lot of I have a lot
that's my grade and regular that's what
I don't know what makes what that's I'm
saying I think high grade and regular
makes submachine gun to gun powders make
bullets I remember that
go to yeah go to high grade let's keep
going up remember when I combined two
high grade and I made submission with
gunpowder make acid rounds yeah so
combine that with a regular gunpowder
high grade and regular yeah so this yeah
and I think you should be good there you
go and now you're going up the stairs
do you see mr. axe didn't have his hat
on you knocked it off Oh does he get it
back is it like yeah
Arthur Morgan no like [ __ ] mr. X and his
hat um so I'm going up yeah going up the
stairs and then what into the shower
room am I just um yeah what what like
brilliant advice well you need to lose
him that's why it was complicated speed
I lost him though didn't I - I [ __ ]
hear him at this point like it's gonna
be probably more about doing the puzzle
a little by little while you like cat
and mouse him
well maybe not maybe will are my plan
will sort of work out in the end so yeah
I go upstairs
scheisse
my god don't run sorry
I got scared they got reported up that
window we would have had so many more
calamities if we didn't dude I should
have boarded up like ten windows yeah
that hallway became a nightmare because
I didn't really give you good important
advice so now I just followed this all
the way around I hate going through the
showers I hate it I hate it it's just
just bang it around all the way down all
the way all the way down yeah dude I
feel like you've made me run the map
twice today yeah I did maybe even three
times now at this point I got my steps
in please don't show up please give me a
[ __ ] break it's straight right
straight and then left into the lounge
just give me a [ __ ] break
alright now you're going toward the
crank on the other side of these
bookshelves that application point okay
so [ __ ] item yes you have it it's
that yellow thing all right so first
just go over to the moveable bookshelves
there's a handgun ammo that we can grab
that's like pretty much under a
bookshelf just you don't need a map just
go to the X go across the room
oh god I [ __ ] hear him okay um so put
right now just put the crank in that
okay I feel like that was loud
yeah if I was like this a dude who heard
stuff I would hear that so you're gonna
move now now you're basically just
bridging that gap so I think I mean this
isn't even something I don't think I
need to explain this just look up and
see where you need to move those it's
it's simpler than it looks like move the
far right one to the right I believe or
like look up first cuz you might not
need to actually no that's fine I think
yeah that's good
I don't understand that's oh that's good
so move
no no what's good when I said it was
good that's good that's just stop the
one that you just lowered move that all
the way the right
but there's a towel oh there's two more
to your left and there's handgun rounds
under that far left one so also move
that even though it's not necessary to
walk over you gotta move that yeah sorry
I'm just trying to like listen sorry umm
because I feel like he's here or
thinking about me all right now there's
handgun rounds back there okay so up
these stairs yeah and then what across
those bookshelves you just formed okay
and then through that door so this is
the door you would have gotten to right
before I led you it was so funny there's
gonna be a few normal zombies up here so
just brace yourself one thing people
have been pointing out is it's probably
better to shoot them in the legs I still
like the head but the legs kind of are
probably more pragmatic you're in the
main hall again but you're on the
surface or he can come in here though
and where is he
don't freak out he might be downstairs
I know but he could be down another
floor he's not yeah he's not up here so
just sound like he knows it's just cuz
you're literally in the same room even
though it's huge just keep moving you're
not helping yourself by staying here
there's a door up on your right that you
should go through no first okay awesome
this is awesome follow this all the way
around and you can unlock the east
storage room door from
hey I hear more and he hears me so I
don't like any of this yeah it's Kiko
it's like a plant in his ass where is it
he one of the ones who just shot I think
got back up yes you're right nice yeah
so you're pretty much just doing this so
you can unlock a better shortcut now
this opens up this will go to the east
storage room where we were before but
now you have oh my god like so once you
unlock this door you're gonna come back
and go to the clock tower oh my god he's
up here is he yes
no no I heard you I just didn't see him
yeah just keep going just keep on that
way
keep going won't wait keep going one way
um so there's two zombies I don't know
I'm trying to think now I don't think
he's there but I also don't doubt you
because you saw him before what I didn't
I where I saw him but now I'm like oh
there's I didn't go in here that's where
we're going like that's where we're
going but I wanted you to unlock this so
now see now we have like the overall
loop I thought I saw him I felt like I
did I don't think you have anything to
lose by going forward a little bit to
see if he is up here and if not just go
to clock tower period yeah as well this
just yeah for this next one let's do a
different straight okay and then go down
the stairs um okay so here's the thing
I'm like almost fairly certain he
because there's this you basically just
have to do yeah you could just you might
want to go to the chief's office just
down the stairs and do that door you
could save if you want from there cuz
now we're like right near where we need
to go with that new door unlocked
yeah hard right yeah deep I saw his dumb
jacket
all right we can do this how long does
it take before he [ __ ] off I have no
idea so now like basically what you just
are waiting for is him to either go
outside or downstairs cuz once you do
like you could just make them you can
book it for the clock tower
oh wait [ __ ] Holly [ __ ] this was almost
really bad go get the large gear from
your item box okay so we really we
actually did need to come back here okay
I planned this all of course you did
yeah you need the large gear wow that
would have been bad because we would
have gotten there and then I would have
said [ __ ] we forgot a key item oh I'm
not feeling well thinking about how bad
that would have been let me ask you this
I left a couple's arms in this vicinity
what should I do about that and we're
not positive that those other two right
there are dead either no you're gonna
come back this way to use the electrical
panels so I know it's gonna be loud but
you're probably better off killing them
okay let me ask you this when I go into
the clock tower
can I just go through he can can he kite
I think he can so you're not like in the
clear if you get in there but it's still
like where we want to go do you think
he's upstairs or down I don't know if
he's downstairs that's awesome if he's
upstairs
run back kinda just have to wait okay so
upstairs upstairs storage room here
yeah and you're gonna have to do like
some quick zombie killing he's upstairs
based on foots I think you're good I
think he's downstairs he's so [ __ ]
loud he's so funny yeah just [ __ ] yeah
those other two zombies are annoying um
oh now you're offense that's are loud
just know what this is you're going a
hard right I am going the wrong way I
want to go this way yeah there's gonna
be two zombies like right on the other
side of the store I think you just like
either just kill this dude in front of
you [ __ ] waste him
you're fine
no one helped I hit l1 I thought but
here we are
should I go to the clock tower I can't
hear you when I take those off what
should I go into the clock time oh my
god I don't think so that was the most
he was just watching me get eaten by a
zombie he was like waiting his turn so
he took a ticket at the meat counter
that's just genders number 76
that's the closest I've come to
physically pooping my pants since I was
like eight years old I think we just
saved in the chief's office right yeah
okay so here's what I think I think you
just go for the clock tower [ __ ] if
we die and he comes in there we'll go
out in a blaze of glory this episode if
not then whatever what do I do in here
[Laughter]
you are you have the big year you need
to pick up the small gear and then which
I believe is right to your right or
farther into the room yeah pocket let's
read first yeah so see the gear tier
right yeah I can kind of see it I
believe that's where you oh you get the
small gear there oh okay I think yes oh
no yeah I just put the large gear in
maybe that might not fit totally does
leon's what do I want to do here now you
going up those stairs I just lowered but
you got to go around yeah around there
he didn't come in here right there um I
don't have a gear for this I thought it
was in here somewhere
um oh no no no you go upstairs to get it
I believe so go up those stairs just
lowered and you should find it up there
and then that will let you lower the
elevator he didn't come in here he can't
come in here you can see that electrical
box right there that's the next the
second one you need and then you're good
small gear right there there might be
something else up here I don't was
taking gears from important pieces of
equipment like the Back to the Future
clock tower um there was like oh just go
back downstairs and start the small gear
and you'll have the battery part pretty
much okay I really feel like he can't
come in here that makes sense cuz it is
a dead end it would be really mean but
it also wouldn't surprise me because
this game is so mean okay right now you
have the battery part electrical part
whatever what that should I don't have a
battery no no sorry unpause it should
lower though elevator
and I'm getting it in the elevator no no
no it's gonna fall and break it maybe
you have to go back upstairs and [ __ ]
touch it
I hear him I think you're right I don't
think he's gonna come in here um do you
need to put the large gear on that to
[ __ ] it up I don't know yeah maybe get
the large gear back from the original
stairs if your mate you're trying to
break the Bell so it falls and knocks
down though so I think maybe I just like
I'm like permanent anxiety this dude's
gonna kool-aid man in here any second
now just ruin my day
yeah I'm not using this gear so no I
don't think so you're I think you just
bring that back upstairs and [ __ ] up the
gears and there you go oh that was you
okay I also like maybe 45 minutes ago
when you were freaking out hearing him
that was me hitting the table like that
oh my god you're saying you were sensing
him and I was curious if he would it
would sound like him
so yeah just
here we go
that worked
it also made a lot of noise what so yeah
now that we have that we have both
electrical parts and we can open up that
gate yeah you got no you got to go back
underneath the chief's office but this
is probably a good time to save it and
getting back to the save room will be
interesting yeah I really don't want to
redo all this so if you want let's talk
about it I think you'll be fine I don't
think they would put keep him outside
yeah I don't know I mean like literally
you just so there's two ways to go right
and the easier way to go would be the
way I originally came so take a lass
that's literally right above where you
need to go next so I would just do that
I get that you might be there but no go
straight out this door and then to the
east side of the main hall to the east
storage room oh just keep in mind there
is like because that's right above the
chief's office which is right above
where we're going next I do if I shoot
these guys he's gonna come right yeah
but you're go you're gonna be on the way
to the save room anyway Oh
I hear him just go where is he I don't
know it doesn't matter you just gotta go
to savor my rage
oh I see what you're saying it doesn't
matter if he's over here yeah you're
fine you're in the clear
whiskey brewing should I shoot him I
don't don't worry about it right now
where is he
I feel like I deserve to know how much
danger I'm in
yeah there's now you're going down the
stairs and saving there was a zombie in
here though no no he like busted through
the door at the last minute when you
came back through that way last night
well there was some real ups and downs
on this episode yeah I started off
pretty boring and then became pretty not
boring just to refresh my memory and
make me feel like I'm not crazy can you
pull up the map again yes I'm almost
yeah you're going right downstairs again
no sorry not right downstairs right
across the hall in the private
collection room okay okay sweet here
I'll just we can say that for next
episode that'll give you the keycard the
garage and that leads to a whole nother
box of worms great well thanks everyone
for joining us on this eventful episode
of resin can evil I don't know I don't
even know what episode it is we've got
to be near 150 by now I think yeah yeah
we celebrated a hundred well I didn't
really dress up or anything but you did
yeah we'll be back next week have a good
rest of your weekend
getting towards February and we'll be
back next week we'll do the garage key
card the well I don't want spoil
anything we'll do some stuff okay
and thanks again for the fan art say gee
I believe his handle and as always if
you have any join the discord group
which is Nathan Shepherd our friend
always posts it in the comments below if
you're on YouTube watching this hey oh
right we haven't done that in a while
Nathan knows as always our is also our
like resin can evil bookie so to speak
our accountant sorry and keeps track of
our deaths and wasted ammo yes no it's
collectively
but yeah as always thanks for the fan
art everybody if you have any that you
happen to be working on put it in the
discord or send it to us on Twitter or
whatever because we love it clearly as
you can see up here make me look jacked
like that does and I'll be happy
make me look disappointed and Mike yeah
pretty much that just follow those
themes and you'll be set so eight we'll
see everybody next week thanks for
joining us always bye bye remember when
you said you almost pooped your pants I
lied I did move my pants